you and anna is a reality tv feud
for the ages
why is there this tension between the
two of you what do you think is the is
the reason behind
it well i'd like to say that because
she's
older i hope that she would be a little
bit wiser than me
um and i do have a lot to learn
of course and i'm still going through
the process where i'm learning
who i can and cannot trust if you cross
her line this is gonna cut you [ __ ] how
come christine's not sitting here
i want to know if um you're aware of all
the kind of cat and mouse game of you
and anna all season long of all the
little tricks she pulled on you
all the little digs you took at her
i'm aware of quite a few of them and you
know
i think it's i think she enjoys um
some of those uh i think she enjoys the
game playing
and i'm a happy participant what do you
think is at the core of that dynamic why
do you two
feel the need to mess with each other
the way you do insecurity
and security do anything to anybody i am
me
and i not that i'm any better than
anybody
that is different but i don't
need to prove anything as much as
know who you are inside for that being
said i hope that everybody finds
happiness
so what is your hope for that
relationship with christine moving
forward
is it a friendship is it this continued
kind of
frenemy place what do you hope happens
next
i wish i had the right christine
[Laughter]
that was a joke um yes i would like to
be her best friend
no that wasn't i i don't know it is what
it is
it will become whatever it is my hope in
moving forward between
anna and i is that we focus our energy
not even
on friendship per se but really on
things that
matter more i hope that we'll put the
necklace skate aside
and put our money put our
money towards better causes do you
regret any of those messy moments
there's the yoga invitation the changing
of the
the place cards there's the giving her
the wrong
time to come to one of your events do
you regret any of that or
is it all in good fun i think he's in
good fun i don't regret anything
regret's the one thing you can never
take away right
right he said whatever it's done is done
like no however
it's important to always keep some
fun in one's life any regrets from
season one
the anal comment maybe oh
you know i i say it really
in a form of like awe and admiration
i mean i have to mention i did have
um a sex uh
sex black tie sex soy a couple years ago
at the chateau marmont penthouse
she has a sex party so she claims
yes i don't think that was great
okay sex party
and i don't think that we should shy
away from
things that make us happy i know it
sounds a little bit taboo
um but you know i give anna all the
credit she deserves for
being you know adventurous
in her um personal life she has a penis
pump
why does she have a penis pump in their
shower
i just heard penis and hope i'm hoping
that makes her happier and makes her a
happier person because
she's having happier moments in the
bedroom there ain't no jake
that good season one is really this cat
and mouse game a lot
woven through anna and christine um
for the queen bee title i guess who do
you think
won out in season one christina
anna hands down no competition not none
at all none i don't know if christine
has a chance they say hannah
i mean you know anna for me that's my
vote i said
i mean i feel like anna's like always
anna's always been that position i don't
think like she ever kind of came down
from it so
um a weapon
weapon what guns i would not mess with
anna
yeah don't mess with the other no
i didn't even know that until now i was
like wanting to keep my mouth shut her
father
sells bombs guns i think it's very
important to have fun
i will be surprised to see if christine
did nothing wrong with christine being
queen bee but just not in this group
that's for sure
find a different group to be queen beef
i like to think that
both anna and i have grown from those
arguments
and that we are both
older and wiser do you have a favorite
prank might not be the right word but a
move you pulled on christine like
a favorite jab you you tossed her away
this
seat first season no i mean
if anything if it looks like i did it
wasn't meant to be
just it kind of like at that moment but
um
perhaps next season i can think of one
there you go that would be great
[Music]